if Superman just snapped when he was a
kid and killed people
the trailer for this I was like I'm in
[Music]
right burn so bright burns basically in
Elseworlds Superman story it's like what
would happen if Superman landed in
Kansas was raised by mom pock Hansen and
what he was 13 years old guess he's just
kind of a psychopathic serial killer bad
save who's physically superior to
anything on earth so now he's just gonna
kill people but the story's made by a
different studio so they can't same on
pockets or Smallville or Clark or
Superman kal-el any of that totally
different names instead the main kid
who's Superman not Superman's name is
Brandon I have just told you the premise
it's like Superman if he snaps started
killing people when he was a boy which
been doing something like this when I
saw the trailer I was like all right
clearly it's gonna have that horror
movie vibe but is it going to be a
clever deconstruction of the Superman
character and it's not really not it's
pretty much horror maybe this a want I
had after seeing the trailer but I think
it would have been really cool for a
movie to basically take the Superman
culture the Superman character you just
deconstruct it and call [ __ ] on the
whole thing because if you have a
thirteen-year-old boy like kids suck
anyway right they're all trying to
posture like they're tougher than each
other you have one who's actually
tougher than anything on earth people
are gonna die there's gonna be good and
if he does end up being good people are
gonna die along the way before he learns
hey maybe I shouldn't kill people
definitely a couple of accidental deaths
right I guess it just would have
preferred or enjoyed if not a more
tragic descent a deeper deconstruction
but really it is just it's harder when
people die that said how are the thrills
how is the horror how are the deaths
they're all right ones particularly cool
and it would have seen it as cooler if I
didn't see it an injustice gods among us
first a couple of stalking scenes here
and there that showed promise but it's
not like this is made by someone who's a
veteran of the horror movie failed or
anything like that the thing that keeps
this movie afloat is its genius premise
Superman but he's bad in a world where
most movies of any genre comedy horror
whatever are telling a story a character
story I always think this movie would
have benefited by being about a half an
hour longer and telling a character
story about someone's
Oh decline into villainy like have
Brandon be a good kid maybe he has a bit
of a chip on his shoulder and then he's
slowly with his superpowers does one
thing that he sees as justified then
another thing that's a little more
hardcore but still justified in his
mind's eye and then before he knows it
he's a villain kind of like Dane DeHaan
and chronicle woulda liked it better if
it did that instead they go the easy
route they saved themselves about a half
an hour of character development they're
just like well he got a message in his
brain from a ship and now he's just mad
but as a movie that's essentially
Superboy the stalker who stalks and
kills a few people in Smallville that's
not actually Smallville that's pretty
entertained by it in the end I will say
bright burn is a good time no alcoholic
wire thanks for your patience on me
reviewing this one a lot of people have
been requesting this all week it's just
that there was no Seattle screening for
bright burns which is never a good sign
last movie that didn't have a Seattle
screening for me was a Hellboy fight so
I was actually going into this movie
expecting a bit of a bus fire maybe
that's why I walked out pretty
pleasantly surprised so again thank you
for your patience and thank you all for
clicking that like button you've been
clicking that like button more lately
it's been helping the videos helping my
channel out thank you for that that is
the game of YouTube we've been playing
the game pretty well lately so thanks
again alright so bright burn have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's another superhero you want to see
an evil else world non-licensed take on
whoever it is whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]